i will never forget the violence of the
white mob
when we left our home i still see black
men seeing being shot
black bodies lying in the street i still
smell smoke and sea fire
i still that was viola fletcher the
oldest known living survivor of the
tulsa race massacre
testifying before a house subcommittee
and calling for justice and reparations
for survivors
and their descendants one hundred years
ago this monday the tulsa oklahoma
neighborhood of greenwood
went from a flourishing business
district known as black wall street
to ruins in a matter of days with the
loss of hundreds of innocent lives
i sat down with some of those
descendants to recall the past
and shine a light on a path forward
[Music]
hark the sounds of roaring battle as
they charged without relent
shooting women men and children plying
torches as they went
this firsthand account of the tulsa
massacre
black men like the ancient trojans
fought and died to save a cause
was written by tulsa's star
editor-in-chief
aj smitherman the great-grandfather
of seth bryant with banners flying high
yet the thing of more importance is the
way they fought and why
it's still very emotional for you this
yeah i mean is this what we call
generational trauma
i've always been scared of lynchings
i've always been scared of like mobs
but he wasn't scared of lynchings and
mobs he ran two lynchings
including the one threatening his
hometown
smitherman was one of the many founding
fathers of greenwood
a community in tulsa oklahoma so rich in
economic power
it came to be known as black wall street
their clientele was black white native
american mary elliott's great great
uncle
t.j elliott owned a hotel theater
bank and a chain of department stores my
uncle
was on the executive committee of the
national negro business league worked
very closely with emmett scott and
booker t washington
and they used their economic power
to empower other african americans
jb was able to hand down a positive
legacy
nate callaway is the great great
grandson
of hotelier jb stratford he had already
started several businesses
put himself through college put himself
through law school but his crowning
achievement was
his hotel which was the largest black
owned hotel
in america all three are a striking
representation of greenwood during that
time
greenwood was a place where people could
come with their vision
of a better world something
anthropologist marlon hall
is passionate about preserving if you
were here
you would see the hustle and the bustle
of a metropolis
you would see this ecologically friendly
community that had
every kind of store you imagined the
folkloric motto of this community was
if we didn't have it you don't need it
black families flocked to the oklahoma
territory fleeing a post-civil war
south these black people went into a
space that they thought they could
actually fulfill their dreams of what it
means to be free
manifest their freedom and they did but
amidst all that success
there were growing tensions resentment
by the white community
scapegoating blaming the black community
greenwood
for the vice in the community by 1907
oklahoma became a state quickly enacting
segregation and voter suppression laws
like
others in the south that helped give
rise to
even more division it was a powder keg
looking for a match so to speak
on may 31 1921 an
elevator ride in a downtown office
building
lit that keg a young man named dick
rowland was accused of
trying to rape a young white woman named
sarah page
someone heard a scream and the
assumption was that he was the attacker
my great grandfather was very attuned to
what was happening
he made the call to the local black men
that we have to go down to the
courthouse and stop
this mob so as the mob grew tensions
grew
things got out of hand a shot was fired
by dawn
several violent clashes had broken out
the most destructive
by air
[Music]
they brought airplanes and they bombed
greenwood
there was no help for the blacks there
was nothing to stop
that mob j.b stratford tried to save his
hotel
the national guard came and told him
that he needed to leave they promised
him that his hotel would
not be destroyed of course as soon as
they pulled him out of the hotel
a mob stormed the hotel ransacked it
looted it and set it on fire as many as
300 people were killed
and the entire greenwood business
district was leveled
the family's home was burned down with
my great grandmother and the children in
the basement
they were able to get out but they had
to flee
by defending themselves and escaping the
mayhem
many became fugitives from justice
accused of
inciting those riots stratfor fled to
kansas and then chicago where he
practiced law
he lived out his life in relative
comfort he was never able to rebuild
what he had built in tulsa t.j
elliott's tulsa store was destroyed but
his muskogee location remained in the
family
until the 1970s smitherman
landed in buffalo where he started
another newspaper
the empire star so this is the first
time you've seen these newspapers
this is the first time that i've
actually touched paper copies of the
empire star
newsprint newsprint frankly we didn't
know that any of these copies existed
when you look at the mary elliotts and
the seth bryants and the nate calloways
how are they part of that that diaspora
that dream realized they are the sacred
echoes of a statement
first made in tulsa about
what happens when you give black folk a
chance
they represent this continuum
of something that was certified in tulsa
mary elliott is a curator at the
smithsonian's
national museum of african american
history and culture
seth bryant leads one of the largest
black law firms in new york city
and nate callaway produces film and
television
in los angeles what is the lesson of
greenwood
it was a community of what's possible if
people are allowed to
achieve their goals allowed to pursue
their passions and live their dreams
all have reclaimed their legacy we're
made up of
lawyers doctors financiers filmmakers
artists judges the biggest thing i could
tell you
about surviving a thing like tulsa
is the word community kinship transcends
blood relationship
we can have that again it's hard to see
because it's not physically in tulsa
but it's happening and i just think that
we just have to keep on that path and
never give up the hope
and the hope is in the descendants those
the child their children's
children who carried on and been
extremely successful you saw three there
i mean the historian known to black folk
john hope franklin was a descendant so
is the
major investor john rogers of ariel
capital and even our own donna bacchus
here at
oh yeah cbs news correspondent great
peace michelle yeah really great